hello everyone and welcome to Game
eleven of the 1972 World Chess
Championship match between Boris Vasudev
its passkey and the Robert James Fisher
now Fischer is in the lead a six and a
half to three and a half and the things
are not looking all that great for the
world champion Boris Spassky his second
Nicolas Fergus was invited to two or
three days at the visit mask of the
report and world champions poor showing
in Reykjavik but Spassky strictly
refused that Kroger's doesn't go and
Kroger said that's definitely the best
decision there's no point in crying over
spilt milk our world champion is down
three points and you know we just have
to find a way how to resurrect him so in
the previous game Fischer defeated
Spassky in his favorite line of the the
breadline of the rule opus and that was
a very impressive feat so here Boris
doesn't really have a choice he has the
striker Fischer is strongest he has to
once again like in Game seven
tried to get get some sort of an edge in
the night Rose variation of the Sicilian
so without further ado Spassky has the
white pieces and the world champion in
game 11 opens with E for so Fischer of
course when he saw this he knows that
Spassky definitely prepared something
but as Fischer is considered to be the
greatest expert on the night off you
know he plays c5 Knight to f3
we have d6 d4 C captors on d4 Knight
captures on d4 and Knight to f6
we have niced the c3 and the now a6 the
knight of variation is on the board rush
up to g5 everything the same like in
game 7 we have e six and now F four and
although Spassky is down three points in
the match he's you know Nikolay says
that he has been known to come back from
worse situation so not the right of
Boris just yet
and here we have Queen to b6 the
poisoned pawn variation Fischer is
inviting Spassky to to to offer his pawn
very nicely like he did he did in game 7
and so Spassky does we have Queen to d2
a favor accepts the pawn queen captures
unbe - and now comes Knight to b3 the
idea is the same the threat
if if Fisher made a silly move like
Bishop to e7 let's say than a3 is coming
and now rook to a2 would be a threat to
win the Queen of course you don't win
the Queen you will win a piece after
something like tonight's the c6 or okay
- and now Knight captures on e4 but
still rook captures Knight captures here
and then after King captures so you will
have one upon one a piece and have a
much better game so of course Fischer
doesn't want to allow this a like in
Game seven Fischer place Queen to a3 and
the now comes Bishop captures on f6 in
game 7 Spassky played Bishop to d3 but
in this game he will leave the d-file
open for for some possible attacks so
here at first he plays the Bishop
captures on f6 he messes up first
respond structure on the Kings side G
captors on f6 and now comes the Bishop
to e2 again a new move
Spassky is preparing Bishop to h5 to
hone in on this f7 pawn so Fischer has
to waste a move here to prevent this he
plays h5 and here comes castles by
Spassky and here fresher plays Knight to
c6 this is not a new position this was
all played before here the standard idea
is something like Knight to d7 followed
by knife to c5 you exchange a knight for
this night on b3 and then your queen can
come back into the game
Fischer goes for a different idea
instead of knight c6 he goes Knight to
d7 sorry instead of Knight to d7 he goes
nice to see six what's some similar
ideas perhaps this Knight can come to a
five and exchange it for the night on b3
and get the Queen back into play this
way King to h1 and this seems like a
very prophylactic move and often in
positions like these when you have this
diagonal open when the Queen and the
dark square bishop might use this
diagonal for some future combinations
it's often it's often a very good move
but here both both gligar itch and crow
goose I consider this to be somewhat a
waste of time
a move that Spassky had prepared they
think he should have plated immediately
without King to h1 but you know he's the
world champion who are you to question
his king - h1 Bishop to d7 by Fischer
now this
tonight the c6 followed by Bishop to d7
was very much criticized by the
commentators they thought that he should
have immediately gone for this exchange
with Knight to a5 but with this he
allows Spassky to go for his very nice
move for this move
Spassky spent over 30 minutes over the
board so later after the game everyone
thought that it was a prepared variation
that you know some group of strong
grandmasters was was called in Moscow to
find some some ingredients to beat
Fischer's poisoned pawn variation and
that they came to this move but as
possibly they'd spent over 30 more 30
minutes on this move and after the game
Spassky said that he found it over the
board
so I mean who are we to not trust Boris
Spassky Knights to be one comes with an
attack on the Queen and here it's
interesting that Fischer spent more time
than Spassky on his next move trying to
figure out all of the variations because
now the Queen doesn't really have all
that many squares Queen to a4 is a
possibility but Fischer decides against
it after Queen to a4 a3 is definitely
coming threatening Knight to c3 to win
the Queen but now after Knight to e7 the
Queen does have a retreat square and c6
for example after Knight to c3 Queen can
come to see six but Fischer decides
against this the knight can keep on
attacking the Queen and it can get very
dangerous for black so instead official
goes Queen to b4 immediately offers a
trade of Queens but Spassky simply moves
the Queen Queen to e3 and now is again
threatening a3 and the nice to see three
to win the Queen for example if
something like seven were played than a3
Queen to a4 and now Knight to c3 will
win the Queen so after Queen to e3
there were a lot of a lot of ideas here
well it's it's not all that easy to find
how to wiggle your queen out chief
arbiter a lot of Schmidt suggested that
f5 should be played you know a nice a
nice pawn sacrifice so you can make some
advances in the center to make some room
for your queen Fischer's idea is similar
only he advances with the deep on but
this doesn't really work the best idea
here was simply night back to e7 you
have to free the c6 square for your
queen after the queen is attacked then
you can go Queen to a4 followed by Queen
to c6 and it's a very passive position
for black but it does seem to be like
the way to go
Fischer goes d5 he tries to sacrifice
the point again some some room for the
Queen
but here comes he captures on d5 Fischer
goes Knight to e7 now making some room
for the Queen and now comes c4 this
seems to be the move that Fischer missed
during his long long calculation because
now it's it's not all that clear huh
what's to play here for black if you
play each character's on d5 you get
Knight to c3 now attacking the d5 pawn
and after D captures on c4 now comes
Knight to d5 attacking the Queen and
before attacking with a double attack on
the night and e7 also threatening Knight
captures on f6 and after Queen to d6
defending now comes Bishop captures on
c4 b5 and now even night
the c5 the a crazy position but black
black is very limited with what he can
do if pawn captures it then comes the
night capture Sun b7 Queen you cannot
capture if you capture with the Queen
then you get use the Queen night of
seven with a nice fork and if you
capture with the King then comes Knight
b6 with a check and forking the rook
after a king moves Knight captures an a8
yeah was Paschal would be of the
exchange and also with with a winning
position
so after c4 Fischer tries a different
idea he tries in Knight to f5 would an
attack on spassky's Queen and simply
Queen to d3 and here it's again if you
try something like e captors on d5 again
you get nice to see 3d captures and now
Queen to e4 with Czech Queen to e7 and
now you get Queen capture some b7
threatening to capture the rook here
after the rook moves rook F 2 c1
threatening the discoveries white is
white is much better here
so after Queen
three Fischer tries an active plan but
you know the position is much too
passive for her for an active plan
Fischer tries eight four Fischer is
hoping for some ideas like Bishop to c5
either a bishop or a queen to c5
for example if this Knight were to
capture the bishop to control the G 1
square and then Knight the g3 check
would be deadly
because after pawn captures pawn
captures would be checkmate
so here Spassky plays the best move he
plays Bishop to g4 not allowing this
plan and now ideas like nice to g3 check
will be met with simply captures and
after captures the bishop to h3 blocking
the check and after ek after Sun d5
opening up a discovered attack from the
bishop to the bishop
you can simply play C capture some d5
Spassky calculates everything precisely
after Bishop captures pawn captures rook
captures with Czech king g2 and white is
without any problems here the rock is
under attack rock h2 gives nothing you
will simply capture and again attack the
rook so after the rook goes back you can
simply start developing the rook is
coming into the into the game the other
rook can also come to the e-file white
will simply enjoy his extra piece so
after Bishop to g4 Fischer tries Knight
to d6 and here comes a knight
1 2 d2 by Spassky if he captures if d
captures on e 6f Jefferson e6 and Queen
to g6 check King to e7 is alright for
Fischer and here space least thought
thought that it would be very hard to
predict what would happen here it's a
crazy position so as poss he doesn't
complicate things after night the first
Rose Knight to d6 Spassky was night one
to d2 Fischer goes f5 and there's really
no good move here for black black can
simply wait and see what white does Rudi
g8 is no better so here official tried
f5 but even if ruby gata3 is coming
there's nothing to do about this and now
again if you go to a 4 if Queen a4 then
comes Queen to c3 Queen to see three a
very nice idea attacking the undefended
rook on h8 but also threatening Knights
the c5 to win the Queen but you don't
even have to play Queen to c3 you can
also go immediately
to see five this would again be winning
but it requires a bit more calculation
but nice to see three Oh Queen to see
three after this a three Quintus III
would be a very nice human winning move
so after a three official goes Queen to
b6 and now comes c5 I have a nice idea
because now after Fischer is the Queen
to b5 offering a trade of Queens yes if
you capture the Knight captures you can
no longer capture the night but now
Spassky uses this fact that the rook on
h8 is undefended
the knight is now attacking the rook is
attacked but there is an even greater
threat because a four will still win the
Queen so there is really nothing Fischer
can do here if you try something like a
5 to make room for the Queen ok you can
say that white the bishop is also
attacked on g4 it doesn't really matter
simply a 4 after Queen moves to a 6 then
Queen captures and h8f captors and g4
you can capture here and you can't even
castle - maybe claim that you have
something here if you Castle them Queen
to c2 recheck going after c7 King here
and you will even lose the other rook
so after Queen to c3 Fischer plays F
captures on g4 he decides to give up his
queen and hope for some perhaps some
contract control play against the
Spassky skink we have a for attacking
the Queen and now h3 a capture some b5
Spassky snatches the Queen and now we
have h captures and g2 with check King
to g2 and now rook to h3 attacking
Spassky screen Queen to f6 now comes
Knight to f5 c6 is coming I mean
statistics is played Bishop back back to
see it and now D characters on e6f
captures an e6 and now rook F 2 e1
simply with a double attack against the
d6 pawn bishop to e7 by Fischer and here
after Spassky played his 31st move local
characters on e6
it was in this position that Spassky
that Fischer decided to resign the game
if you capture a Pascal or simply
capture and there is nothing more to do
here
93 check will be met with King - g1 and
now there is no way to continue this
attack in
anyway rook e1 is coming and it is all
over so yeah especially managed to win
game 11 and it is the first game Bey
well we can say that this is actually
the first game he won in this match
because the first game Fischer simply
defeated himself and in the second game
Fischer didn't show up for the game so a
very nice victory a spectacular victory
we might say as he beat fisher fisher in
the and not a poison potent variation of
the night off line that he is famous for
at that if he enjoys playing with both
black and white pieces and he really
crushed him in 30 moves so also a very
funny thing was said by american
grandmaster madness who said that
Fischer's d5 the pawn sacrifice in this
game got him
a lost position so you know you usually
sacrifice a pawn for something here
Fischer sacrificed upon for a for a lost
position but yeah six two five two four
and six and a half to four and a half
Spassky lowers fish was lead to two
points and it's you know it's still a
match did it was a Spassky resurrected
here after this victory it's hard to say
but it is the first game that probably
the first game that really shook Fischer
as he did lose in his favorite line and
also it is the first game where Fischer
had last time on his clock then Boris
Spassky so now that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to think how
a Lieberman can Stefan last name Patrick
Thomas again called he an economist and
lorina watt for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos your thing called for watching
and I'll see you soon with another bobby
fischer video but also i will check up
on some of your suggestions so we can
you know include a video or two in
between the series thank you all and
I'll see you soon